[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de dimanche
en politique la franche-comté notre
région possède cinq mille trois cent
cinquante kilomètres de cours d'eau
parmi ceux-ci 4549 pour lesquelles la
pêche est possible à leurs problèmes
avec la sécheresse les poissons meurent
par milliers par millions on dit que les
abeilles sont d'excellents indicateurs
de la qualité de l'air les poissons
remplissent aussi sur le rôle
cette fois ci pour l'eau face à cette
sécheresse et aux conséquences pour
l'environnement que faire on en débat
avec nos invités tout d'abord mathieu
perez c'est le trésorier de la
fédération de pêche du territoire de
belfort
face à lui didier chapuis le directeur
adjoint de la ddt la direction
départementale des territoires du doubs
et puis jean noël rech hydrobiologiste
chargé de mission au syndicat mixte des
milieux aquatiques du haut doubs
n'oubliez pas vous pouvez réagir
commenter cette émission grâce à twitter
et au hashtag dit mme paul fc comme
dimanche en politique franche comté on
va commencer avec un première premier
tour de table
on manque d'eau est ce que c'est
vraiment une surprise pour vous qui êtes
hydrobiologiste jean-noël rech
est ce que c'est une surprise ou pas une
surprise quand même dans le sens où des
situations catastrophiques comme celle
ci on la vit pas tous les ans et puis tu
en résumant camp du oui par contre une
surprise pas tout à fait dans le sens où
on s'est quand même alors là c'est pour
le pour ce qui concerne le haut doubs
qu'on est dans un secteur extrêmement
fragile et ça fait très longtemps qu'on
sait que le haut doubs est en déficit
hydrique et c'est assez étonnant
d'entendre ça quand on voit la pluie
tomber régulièrement dans ce sur ce
territoire
mais la nature de la roche fait que
l'eau s'infiltre très facilement et
conduit à des problèmes en étiage pour
le territoire de belfort est ce que vous
en tant que pêcheur vous avez remarqué
des rivières en grande souffrance
oui alors clairement nous sommes déjà
très habituée de faire face à des
épisodes de sécheresse de ce genre parce
que l'essayer milieux aquatiques sont
déjà énormément sollicités de parler les
pressions qui peuvent subir mais de
cette ampleur si c'est une situation
totalement inédite
et puis vous alors on parlait du des
sols calcaires vous cédez sol karstique
et puis l'eau même si le ballon d'alsace
est très très on va dire rosé toute
l'année l'eau par très très vite dans
les rivières
oui voilà clairement le territoire de
belfort s'identifie par deux types de
nature de sol très différentes
vous avez au nord le secteur très
karstique houle au fait que russell et
et ne peut être contenu dans les sols
donc part très vite par l'intermédiaire
du milieu aquatique et la partie sud du
territoire qui est comporte des poches
de réserve marneuses et qui permet une
perméabilité de l'eau beaucoup plus
importantes n'ont qu'une restitution
plus lente au cours d'eau ce qui
explique que dans le nord du département
des fois il ya des très graves
inondations justement parce que les sols
n'absorbe pas l'eau quand y'a de fortes
pluies alors didier chapuis on va voir
deux chiffres tout d'abord dans le
département du doubs 34 communes sont
actuellement donc ravitailler en eau
notamment par des citernes 34 communes
sans eau depuis déjà plusieurs semaines
et puis on a également une autre carte
cette fois ci celle du département du
doubs on voit que plus du tiers du
département se trouve en situation
difficile que ce soit déjà ravitaillé
par des citernes
ou alors on appelle ça des zones en
tension c'est une situation inédite dans
le département oui c'est une situation
qui est clairement inédite de par son
ampleur et de par sa durée
c'est vrai que il ya eu déjà des
difficultés on fait souvent référence à
2003 pour l'année je dirais la plus
semblable à proximité de deux idées des
gens et mais on est vraiment là sur
quelque chose de particulier cette année
les difficultés ont commencé au mois de
juillet et puis on est maintenant au
mois de novembre et les choses n'ont
fait que s'empirer
et pour ce qui concerne l'eau potable
c'est vrai qu'on est réellement dans une
situation délicate avec vous l'avez dit
34 communes qui sont ravitaillés par des
citernes
il ya aussi des communes qui sont
ravitaillées désormais par le biais d'
je dirais la solidarité entre les
différents réseaux par les
interconnexions qu'ont pu être mise en
place dans certains secteurs donc la
solidarité
l'intercommunalité et l'interconnexion
joue son rôle à plein il ya aussi
d'autres communes qui sont en difficulté
qui sont surveillées aujourd'hui et
c'est vrai que si la situation perdure
on va vraiment arriver sur certains
secteurs dans le dur et puis l'arrêté
sécheresse continue ça veut dire qu'on
n'a pas le droit d'arroser par exemple
ces voitures on a aujourd'hui je dirais
que la question de la rose âgée plus
tellement d'actualité à l'époque ont
aimé par exemple effectivement il faut
toujours pas arroser ne toujours pas
laver ces voitures aujourd'hui
enfin il faut clairement des priorités à
donner et pour nous c'est vraiment de
privilégier l'alimentation en eau
potable l'abreuvement pour les
populations l'abreuvement du bétail les
ressources en eau également pour le
fonctionnement des industries et la
production le système économique après
on peut comprendre je pense qu'il faut
que les gens comprennent que notamment
le lavage des voitures le lavage des
voiries
c'est super c'est superflu je pense que
les gens ont un peu sont un peu trompé
aussi parce que je crois qu'il faut
rendre hommage aux collectivités locales
à ceux qui sont en compétences sur la
gestion de l'eau potable a eu beaucoup
d'efforts de fait et finalement
jusqu'aujourd'hui malgré la gravité de
la situation les gens robinet à
l'horizon un peu une situation courante
ils se rendent pas forcément compte de
la gravité de la situation donc ce oui
mais la situation alors pour les humains
ça va à peu près mars et pour les
poissons que c'est une catastrophe
on va voir tout de suite à un reportage
qui a été effectué il y a huit jours
donc dans le doubs à arçon ça s'appelle
une pêche de sauvetage on regarde
c'est une course contre la mort des
poissons vous vous acharnez pas on fait
un passage rapide ce qui resterait s'il
va pleuvoir ce week-end les pieds dans
les dernières poches d'eau bénévoles
d'associations et fédérations de pêche
se sont retroussé les manches pour cette
pêche électrique de la dernière chance
oui on va sauver tout ce qu'on peut tout
simplement voir ce qui apparemment voir
ce qui ce qui tient coup et puis de
ramener sur sur pontarlier sur douce et
y trouver des trous d'eau brochet
truites perches tanches
au total six tonnes de poissons ont été
sauvés en une seule matinée relâchés
dans le doubs en amont de pontarlier
[Musique]
est-ce que vous dans le territoire de
belfort vous avez fait des pêches de
sauvetage
oui bien entendu dès le 20 juillet nous
serons tous dans l'année nous avons
commencé donc à réaliser des pêches
électriques de sauvetage principalement
sur les secteurs très sensibles nord du
territoire de belfort où c'est que c'est
des cours d'eau à dominante de
salmonidés donc pas si on espèces
patrimoniales
oui voilà la savoureuse donc et les
héroïnes de lepuix germany alors jean
noël rech on voit là une pêche de
sauvetage donc dans le haut doubs et à
côté à quelques kilomètres qui a lack de
bouverans le lac qui s'appelle le lac de
l'entonnoir et là il n'y a pas eu de
pêches de sauvetage est ce que vous nous
expliquer pourquoi ce que déjà c'est
peut-être des propriétaires privés
et eux ils ont décidé de pas le pas le
faire disons qu'il ya des secteurs où
alors c'est vrai que c'est malheureux de
voir tous ces poissons morts nous serait
sous l'eau douce y en émoi depuis le 28
juillet enfin on en rêve des fois la
nuit d'ailleurs c'est ça oui à ce point
là oui ça c'est le roi des images qui
sont pas agréables tout le temps donc
mon ccc c'est une chose qu'on aimerait
bien ne pas avoir à vivre après l'appel
de sauvetage et des fois indispensable
mais des secteurs où ça peut être
compliqué ça peut être difficile il faut
que ce soit efficace aussi faut pas
qu'on tue le reste oui parce que quand
on va pêcher à l'électricité il est
possible qu'on tue les derniers suivi en
fait ceux qui sont déjà un outil pas
malade
c'est un risque c'est un risque sur les
premières les premiers assèchement qui a
eu sur le doubs en juillet quand les
températures étaient très chaude
le moindre coup d'électrodes avaient eu
un effet boeuf plutôt plutôt pape
agréable là les températures sont plus
fraîches donc sur ars sont l'intégration
pêche du doubs a essayé de faire des
pêches de sauvetage qui se sont plutôt
bien déroulées sur le lac de bours ans
effectivement la priver les bleus sont
les propriétaires qui ont qui ont décidé
qu'ils ont pris la décision de ne pas
l'anr vanille parce que le risque de
mortalité qui est quand même très très
important et qui bénéficie d'
d'expérience il avait déjà le niveau
enfin le lac s'était asséchée en 59
beaucoup de personnes disent quand ça
compte neuf ils ont fait ou essayer de
sauver du poisson ce qui est vrai mais
les certaines personnes ou des
propriétaires en 59 ans dit clé les
restes n'étaient pas forcément conclu et
puis en 59
il allait les mettre les poissons dans
de l'eau fraîche dans des fontaines
maintenant il ya moins de fontaine dans
les villages ce qui à ça quand on retire
les poissons de la rivière
il faut savoir où aller mais hélas dans
le haut doubs là pour le moment vous
n'avez pas vraiment d'endroit où les
mettre - il ya des endroits mais il faut
les transporter enfin c'est compliqué de
les transporter en bon état on veut me
sentais si jamais facile vous avez dit
lac saint point et là je vais me tourner
vers leurs représentants de l'état lac
le lac saint-point sert à alimenter en
eau les villages aux alentours mais il
n'y a pas eu de lâchers d'eau pour que
le dos puissent rester quand même
suffisamment alimenté
est-ce que vous pouvez vous justifier
alors le lac saint point c'était un
sujet de discussion et d'inquiétudes
depuis la fin du mois de juillet on a
fait une première réunion lorsqu'il ya
eu les premiers à sec du doubs c'est
spectaculaire assez remarquable et qui
avait un peu choqué déjà la population
et les pêcheurs à la fin du mois de
juillet début du mois d'août donc la
gestion du lac saint point qui et je
dirai sous la responsabilité de l'état
et qui est assurée en collaboration avec
le syndicat mixte des milieux aquatiques
du haut doubs nous a amenés
effectivement à réfléchir aux bons
débits à maintenir dans le doubs il faut
savoir que habituellement sur la période
estivale 1 à 1,5 mètre cube dans ce
village c'est un peu d'eau dans le doubs
suffisait à maintenir un débit continu
sur l'ensemble de la partie amont
jusqu'à jusque notamment à morteau cette
année ça n'a pas été le cas et malgré
l'augmentation des débits lâché au
niveau du lac est allé jusqu'à 3 mètres
cubes c'est assez les instruments il se
passe rien on n'a pas réussi à maintenir
de débit donc déjà dès cette période là
on avait pris la décision qu'a pas
forcément été comprise par tout le monde
de réduire le débit pour préserver la
ressource et le réservoir que constitue
le lac saint point
c'est en fait vous avez choisi la
population autour du lac plutôt que les
poissons dans le doubs
disons que surtout en séries
que malgré un débit très important qu'on
n'avait pu être amené à essayer de
lâcher au lac saint-point n'arrivait pas
à maintenir un débit dans le doubs donc
de toute façon on n'avait pas de
solution pour sauver la population de
poissons dans la partie qui a été un
astérisque c'est un art sont jusqu'à au
défilé entre roche et puis le risque
qu'on avait effectivement en arrière
pensée c'était depuis avoirs de réserve
d'eau par rapport au niveau des pompes
dans le lac saint point les pompes
courante 1 qui aujourd'hui sur un niveau
où on assemble pratiquement désamorcée
et même s'amorcer ça veut dire qu'elles
ne peuvent plus pour les deux
fonctionnent et voilà donc après on il
ya une solution de sauvegarde mais qui
peut aussi servir à desservir l'ensemble
de la population de pontarlier des
environs donc vous comprenez bien qu'il
fallait aussi maintenir ce sera l'été
les gens avant les poissons voilà et
c'est aussi ce qu'ils nous a amené
encore à réduire davantage le débit il
ya quinze jours maintenant puisqu'on a
vraiment arriver à une solution délicate
et c'est là qu'il ya eu la nouvelle
phase de mortalité effectivement des
poissons des votes contre
vous comprenez ce genre de décision ou
ça vous fait un peu mal au ventre
les deux la comprends mais ça fait mal
au ventre mais effectivement pas on est
dans des situations dans l'aude où tout
le milieu tellement fragile et où la
situation est telle qu on est obligé à
cette année de l'état et des oublis de
faire un choix et pire alors à côté nous
vous vous êtes donc un spécialiste de ce
qu'on appelle les milieux aquatiques
c'est aussi bien les rivières les plans
d'eau les marais les tourbières en quoi
un milieu aquatique est important pour
l'environnement pour la vie tout autour
la zone humide et le cours d'eau c'est
la réserve en eau c'est à dire la zone
humide en particulier c'est un grand
réservoir et puis c'est aussi important
pour les inondations que pour les
sécheresses assez importante pour les
deux c'est à dire une zone humide qui
fonctionne bien l'accueil et une rivière
qui fonctionne bien elle déborde un
moment et quand elle déborde elle va
recharger la nappe phréatique et en
recharge de la nappe phréatique ça va
être de l'eau qui est disponible aussi
pour la population pour les fleurs pour
les insectes pour les poissons mais
aussi pour la population
mais malheureusement ces zones humides
quand elles sont drainés bas cette
ressource elle va être elle va diminuer
très fortement une pas être disponible
est pareil dans les cours d'eau quand
les cours d'eau sont rectifiées mal
le niveau a baissé très très vite
mathieu perez on a vu donc vous nous
disiez tout à l'heure que vous avez fait
des pêches de sauvetage que bon les
milieux aquatiques s'en sont aussi
fragiles
chez vous est-ce qu'ils sont très
détériorée compte tenu du fait que le
territoire de belfort
au contraire du haut doubs du moins dans
son ensemble est très urbanisées oui le
département territoire de belfort en
outre la problématique de l'organisation
on est deux fois plus urbanisées que la
moyenne nationale donc il ya énormément
de recalibrage du cours d'eau du coup
les l'accélération du débit est
prépondérante
l'incision se fait l'écho de saint fons
donc la nappe et la déconnexion avec les
zones humides et établit donc ceux ci se
rend compte des problématiques assez
importante
le problème qui peut être identifiée
également c'est les prélèvements qui
peuvent être effectués de façon
anarchique ou par nécessité pour la
population
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas une vision
globale qui peut être rétabli pour
concilier les nécessités d usage humain
avec ceux du milieu naturel
il faut vraiment qu'on puisse établir
une gestion équilibrée de la ressource
en eau potable pour pouvoir fournir de
l'eau en de manière équilibrée c'est
votre rôle ça c'est votre job si j'ose
dire oui disons que notre rôle c'est
d'animer les différentes instances qui
sont en charge de
de la gouvernance de l'eau aujourd'hui
on est dans une phase de prises de
compétences dans le domaine de l'eau au
niveau de ce qu'on appelle la gemme api
gestion de l'eau des milieux aquatiques
et la prévention de la nation d'une part
la prise de compétence aussi a priori au
niveau intercommunal d'ici 2026 en
matière d'alimentation en eau potable et
accessoirement d'assainissement mais
c'est lié et là on est vraiment sur des
sujets très importants et où on rentre
effectivement dans cette question de
vision globale
c'est aussi l'objet par exemple dans le
doubs il ya des choses qui sont un petit
peu en avant sur la partie audio haute
loue avec l'établissement public
d'aménagement une gestion de l'eau qui
devrait se mettre en place au 1er
janvier 2019 qui a vraiment cette
vocation est de globaliser la question
de l'eau et de répartir un petit peu les
usages alors déjà ce qui a été fait
c'est les fameux colorant vert que vous
avez mis dans la rivière pour voir ce
que ça donnait ça sert à quoi ça alors
je pense qu'il faut dire un petit peu à
tout le monde que aujourd'hui même si la
secte du doubs dans la partie arçons
ville dupont défilé dans trust est très
marquante et dure depuis le début du
mois de juillet c'est pas forcément
représentatif de la situation de
sécheresse
un cas vraiment très particulier parce
qu'il faut expliquer qu'il ya des
failles et que l'eau dce pareil qui est
pas notamment dans la halle les failles
historique je veux dire au moment où la
sec s'est produit 20 juillet début août
on était sur des débits potentiel qui
était encore assez important et qui
aurait dû permettre de maintenir un
écoulement
mais c'est vrai que c'est que malgré
tout assez symptomatique est aujourd'hui
sur ce secteur là même s'il ya déjà eu
des recherches historiques
on cherche à mieux comprendre ce qui
s'est passé si on cherche aussi à avoir
un état des lieux établi sur la
topographie du fond du lit du doubs donc
on a fait des relevés topographiques on
a fait de la bathymétrie et on a fait
aussi effectivement les très
spectaculaire par rapport pour savoir
effectivement ou allé lô exactement
parce que a priori l'ovaire laloum on
n'était pas sûr et aussi on voulait
savoir où tu es la limite entre ce qui
va vers la halle où est ce qu'ils
continuent dans le doubs et qui
disparaît est-ce qu'il disparaît et
c'est vrai que là on va demander à va
demander à l'hydro biologiste alors la
première fois que vous avez mis des
colorants ils sont ressortis trois
semaines plus tard et ça faisait quand
même un certain nombre de jours que vous
étiez en train de piaf et au bord des
rivières pour voir où il allait
ressortiez et dans quelles quantités
pour le coloration été faite par les
services de l'état mais effectivement
s'attendait à une sortie beaucoup plus
rapide mme heidi deux trois jours quoi
théoriquement de trois jours ça aurait
dû sortir et puis je pense que c'est lié
aussi au moment où d'où justement
actuelle et puis à la complexité du
système c'est à dire c'est un système
qui que finalement on connaît
relativement peu même si on pense on
pense bien le connaître on doit le
connaître c'est une petite leçon
d'humilité et de modestie peut-être
certainement même si je pense qu'on ne
manquent pas non plus mais jeudi pour
tout le monde dames
mais oui on s'attendait à ce que ça
sorte plus vite et puis ces sorties mais
de manière très directe à c'est à dire
assez c'est assez clair il ya sa part
été dit fumer ça a été très long
donc vous allez renouveler ce genre
d'expérience pour pouvoir connaître
mieux le jeu lui un premier traçage
effectivement qui a été fait sur la
partie demain dira plutôt amont de la
zone d'asec et qui est sorti on est
entièrement la source de la loue et là
elle la deuxième partie qui a été un
objet de vaudou reportages et qui aime
beaucoup enfin qui est très
spectaculaire par la couleur verte dans
les zones un petit peu de deux cuves est
donc là c'est plutôt pour voir ce qu'ils
basculent vers le
le doubs en aval sur la partie de
morteau mais pour l'instant on n'a pas
encore de données sur ce qui est sûr ce
qui reçoit donc si je comprends bien
déjà la première chose à faire c'est
mieux connaître ce qui se passe dessous
et pas que ce disque on le voit en
surface est ce qu'il y à aussi par
rapport à d'autres on a les dix
intervenants sur le milieu je pense aux
agriculteurs des choses à faire et des
choses à ne pas faire comme par exemple
les drainage agricole
alors il faut savoir qu'à un mètre dans
le sol des draps en plastique sont mis
pour évacuer l'eau qui en trop et vous
par exemple pêcheurs vous trouvez que ça
détruit le milieu naturel
pourquoi oui bien sûr ça a détruit
forcément le milieu naturel
parce que la rétention d'eau dans les
sols est nécessaire bien certainement à
l'impact pour la production agricole
mais elle a une certaine utilité elle
permet de restituer l'eau et de dans le
mille dans le lit du cours d'eau
naturels le tour de restituer gentiment
la dranse il m'en excuse mais de façon
plus lente
le problème qui peut être rencontrer
aussi c'est que quand l'eau est facturé
évacuer trop rapidement des terres
arables l aigle aux évacués des
contenants des polluants ces polluants
sont les insecticides qui représente
principalement des ions négatifs qui ne
peuvent pas être contenu dans les sols
et qui ne peuvent pas et épuré donc par
la plantation en période hivernale
donc pendant les fortes plus vieux mais
très automnale les polluants qui sont
contenus dans les sols peuvent rebondir
parvenir plus rapidement
dollé riz blanc et rivières et donc dans
les poissons mais vous aussi vous pensez
que les drainage agricole sont nocifs à
l'environnement et qu'il faudrait
délimité sur le solo est doué syndicat
mixte en particulier on s'occupe
essentiellement de fossés qui ont été un
peu plus anciens d'ailleurs ses défauts
ses rangs zones humides ou en zone
tourbeuses qui a été construit ça pour
gagner des terrains agricoles à l'époque
sur sur ces zones humides soit pour
faire de la deux pour recueillir de la
tourbe pour le chauffage donc le
syndicat mais est ce de la nage il a un
impact bien sûr négatif sur les zones
humides et tout bien et donc il réduit
cédé ce rôle sur le béton alors on va
demander au représentant de l'état est
ce que vous savez combien il ya
d'hectares qui sont drainés dans le
doubs ou pas et
dans le doubs on n'est pas dans un
un milieu agricole ou le drainage est
très répandue c'est très répandu d'un
autre région en août sous d'autres
départements où il ya plus de pratique
de ce type là concrètement aujourd'hui
dans le cadre notamment de la loi sur
l'eau on n'a pas eu à traiter de
dossiers de drainage dans le death qu'il
faut il faut que la parcelle face au
moins 20 hectares pour que l'agriculteur
soit obligé de vous demander
l'autorisation alors c'est vrai que l'on
sait que la limite 20 ha c'est peut-être
un peu haut
en fait bon il ya un seuil qui a été mis
pour cet aspect là est donc strictement
pour le drainage donc il comme vous le
dites à 20 hectares pour une déclaration
est à 100 hectares pour une autorisation
ce qui peut paraître énorme witching
chez nous donc vu les superficies
agricoles oui tout à fait ce qu'il faut
quand même savoir c'est qu'il ya une
autre brique de la loi sur l'eau qui dit
que quand on provoque un assèchement
d'une zone humide alors défini
réglementairement peut-être pas rentrer
dans le détail sur plus de 1000 mètres
carrés on est soumis à déclaration n'est
sur plus d'un hectare n'est soumis à
autorisation vous voyez que ces sujets
là si on y ajoute aussi les différentes
techniques de drainage entre guillemets
13 pas mal de débats la question des
agents de l'état pour contrôler tout ça
parce que pour l'arrêté sécheresse moi
j'ai des questions des spectateurs
notamment neptune qui dit on n'est pas
des ânes informés et puis l'état n'a pas
suffisamment d'agents pour aller
contrôler que ce soit les stations de
lavage automatique
les gens qui ont rempli leur piscine etc
vous répondez quoi alors d'une manière
générale
enfin parent dans ce domaine là comme
dans d'autres on privilégie quand même
les démarches partenariales les
démarches d'information en amont plutôt
que les démarches de contrôle et de
police de l'eau puisque on sait qu'en
fait c'est pas forcément parce que vous
n'avez pas les moyens humains
c'est aussi un choix parce qu'on
s'aperçoit aussi que il vaut mieux
convaincre les gens de l'intérêt de
démarches plus plus vertueuse par
rapport à l'environnement que
d'intervenir simplement à la fin quand
l'atteinte à l'environnement été commise
donc aujourd'hui c'est vrai que nos
forces et les agents qu'on mobilise sur
le sujet de l'environnement sont plutôt
un lamont sur le conseil sur
l'accompagnement de projets sur
20 effectivement le cas échéant financer
aussi des projets de restauration de
zones humides mais on sait aussi
effectivement faire usage du pouvoir de
police et en l'occurrence de police de
l'eau qui nous est donné alors plutôt
dans une démarche pédagogique qui vise
d'abord à faire cesser les les
infractions et les atteintes à
l'environnement et le cas échéant si les
choses perdurent il ya aussi des
procédures administratives ou des
procédures judiciaires qui sont engagées
à l'encontre des personnes pas de
répression déjà de la prévention et de
l'information
vous aussi aux syndicats mixtes vous
prenez là le fait que les rivières ne
soit plus tout droite comme l ont été
donc rectifier il ya quelques dizaines
d'années mais que vous arriviez à
refaire les méandres pourquoi mais je
pense qu'on sait aussi c'est qu'une
rivière qui fonctionne bien qui
fonctionne de manière on va dire naturel
avec l'ensemble de ses fonctionnalités
bah déjà elle est là une certaine
résistance et une certaine résilience
dans des phénomènes météorologiques
comme ce qu'on a ici elle va jouer un
rôle d'épongé ce pour quoi elle est
faite plus facilement c'est ça des jeux
pour reprendre l'eau et pour la re
donner quand il faut ça c'est un service
qu'elle rend on va dire un gros retenir
de l'eau et pouvoir leur donner après ça
c'est le service qu'il peut rendre aussi
à la population
mais en dehors de ça aussi un milieu
fonctionne quand il fonctionne bien il a
plus de résistance aussi même pour lui
même c'est à dire un assèchement sera
moins dramatique qu'en la rue enfin
théoriquement on la rivière fonctionne
bien et en plus sur la rivière
fonctionne bien et quand elle assez
méchante plutôt que d'être rectiligne
par exemple elle va aussi pouvoir se
remettre plus facilement de ces dégâts
qu'elle a pu subir
donc c'est pour ça que le syndicat mixte
fait ce type de travaux également alors
vous avez vous êtes un peu jeune pour
avoir connu la sécheresse de 2003 et et
vous en souvenir
mais ce que vous pensez que les leçons
2003 ont été tirées et que cette
sécheresse de 2018 va pouvoir faire nous
faire progresser collectivement par
rapport à l'ingestion je pense qu'il
faut espérer forcément une amélioration
de la situation globale mais la
problématique que aujourd'hui malgré les
mesures qui vont être prises par les
services de l'état avec des arrêtés
portant restriction des usages de l'eau
avec des seuils de plusieurs niveaux
dans le territoire de belfort on a
atteint le niveau d' arrêter sécheresse
à l'état de crise
y'en a partout de sensibilisation en
franche comté ain nappe est la
sensibilisation qui a été prononcée par
les services de l'état demandant d'
économiser l'eau le territoire de
belfort consomment quotidiennement
journalièrement 20000 mètres cubes par
jour on peut s'apercevoir que malgré au
seuil de niveaux de crise la quantité
n'a pas diminué
donc vous êtes sceptique j'ai un certain
mais est-ce que vous avez noté une
diminution de l'eau ou pas alors par la
force des choses qu'elle n'avait plus
dance and honour mais c'est vrai que
globalement l'impact collectif il n'est
pas énorme et vous avez toujours dit que
les gens n'étaient pas toujours bien
informés c'est un point de vigilance
pour nous et ça fait partie aussi des
enseignements qu'on devra tirer de cette
phase de crise on a nous dans le doubs
essayer de travailler là dessus et fait
des petits bulletins d'information plus
pédagogique qui ont pu être diffusées
dans les mairies et du coup de
rediffuser vers les gens pour les
toucher individuellement
parce qu on a pu noter effectivement un
manque de connaissance des arts était un
manque de compréhension des arrêtés au
delà de fin avec des gens plutôt de
bonne foi parfois kiener qui ne
respectaient pas on sait que quand même
quand il ya une assistance sur le
secteur de morteau qui est le plus
concerné ou les élus locaux les services
et les gestionnaires ont fait beaucoup
d'efforts à beaucoup de pédagogie
il ya quand même eu un impact là sur la
consommation avec des réductions de
l'ordre de 10 15%
certains disent que c'est pas beaucoup
mais vous savez c'est ça permet quand
même des usagers des réseaux et parfois
avec 10-15 % de consommation au moins on
peut passer d'une situation très tendue
à une situation un peu plus confortable
pour la gestion du réseau
on va terminer cette émission avec vous
jean noël rech
est ce que le fait que cette sécheresse
2018 et des conséquences lourdes
est-ce que vous pensez que les leçons
vous être plus j'allais dire évidente
pour les gens que pour la sécheresse de
2003 tout à l'heure on l'espère on
l'espère c'est mais là on a touché le
fond sans gêne mots oui oui on a touché
le fond maintenant c'est pas ce qui ce
qui est devant nous non plus après on
espère pouvoir retenir les leçons qu'on
est content de ce qu'on vit actuellement
pour pouvoir rebondir aussi que que les
travaux et que l'importance qu'ont dit
aussi de cette ressource pour les
milieux naturels puisse puisse
pris par tout le monde enfin que la
muette vous en tant qu hydrobiologiste
maintenant quand vous allez prendre la
parole vous allez être plus pris au
sérieux que ya six mois j'espère alors
c'est vrai que souvent on dit qu'on
travaille pour les petites fleurs des
oiseaux ou des poissons mais est ce
qu'on a envie de dire c'est que ses
parents tiwony que c'est pas parce qu'on
travaille pour le poisson ou pour pour
une fleur protégés de zones humides
qu'on ne travaille qu on va contrarier
contre l'homme c'est pas ça du tout
notre volonté mais des fois vous passez
pour un peu écolo à rire est un peu
contre le progrès et tout ça je sais pas
mais ça peut on peut ça peut être le cas
dès fois de travailler pour des petits
fous on peut nous reprocher travail pour
les poissons des insectes aquatiques ou
des petites fleurs mais les enjeux
derrière son sont ceux ci aussi la
biodiversité est importante mais au delà
il ya aussi cette ressource en eau qui
elle est importante pour l'homme
également ce qui est bon pour les
insectes aquatiques pour les poissons
pour les fleurs et théoriquement bon
également pour l'homme ce n'est pas
antinomique
alors ces jours derniers il pleut un peu
ça suffit pas on est d'accord il
faudrait beaucoup beaucoup plus d'eau
beaucoup plus de pluie ben faut beaucoup
plus de pluies et puis le souci c'est
qu'on va rentrer dans une période froide
ou le gel peut se peut arriver ou sur
écoute pour l'instant rien n'est rien
n'est résolu du tout voilà on va pas
finir sur une très optimiste mais sa
feria merci messieurs d'avoir participé
à cette émission
merci de votre attention bon dimanche à
tous au revoir
[Musique]
parce que la guerre